fox business correspondent Nicole Pat
ladies is live at the new york stock
exchange for a so Nicole Twitter's most
famous clients most famous user hasn't
really done anything for the business
this quarter that's right Emily I know
you're talking about when you say the
most famous user and that is now
president donald trump who has brought
people who never used to twitter ever
before passive users now they're on
twitter as well because they don't want
to miss any of the hot tweets from our
new president however that being said
the company reported its tenth straight
quarter of slowing revenue growth it has
319 million total active monthly users
which pales in comparison to Facebook of
1.86 billion and the question is what
happens with Twitter you could take a
look at a recent tweet of his for
example on Intel but he has used Twitter
to really put out his foreign policy
plans lash out against critics in the
Democratic Party in the media all
together Jack Dorsey returned to Twitter
to the helm in October of 2015 to try
and revitalize this company but the
truth of the matter is they're really
not growing it it hasn't gone beyond
what everybody expected and as a result
it has been a disappointment to
Washington a to Wall Street overall I
will say a good point for Twitter ian is
that they have tried to expand beyond
just tweets now they've moved to live
streaming they have the NFL our National
Football League and that has been very
popular so the live streaming idea is
something that's supposed to bring in
some of the younger viewers and grow the
base of Twitter overall but the truth of
the matter is it really is not surging
and as a result we're seeing the stock
today doubt about eleven percent and it
is down about sixty percent from its
lifetime high back in 2013 so so far not
so great in and i'll leave you with snap
that is going to be the new initial
public offering and that's the parent of
snapchat that's very popular and their
tagline is where the next Facebook not
the next Twitter I mean just say ouch
that's enough radiant let's hope so for
their sake thanks Nicole